- All right. Let's wrap things up
with one more great find to perk you up.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
- So, I'm here once again with
our friend Lawrence Zarian.
And most of you, know Lawrence,
as an incredibly talented
man with a huge personality,
a lot of friends and I love him.
But you're about to meet a very different
humbling side of our friend.
So Lawrence tell everybody
about this passion project
that you've been working on.
- First of all, thank you
for letting me do this.
- Absolutely.
- But I am so excited. You know,
I am able to officially launch,
a lifelong dream of mine,
and that is my own
collection called CAxLZ,
in partnership with Connected Apparel.
And this collection is
designed and created
for women of all shapes,
ages and glorious sizes
to look beautiful. But
most of all, feel gorgeous.
- Love it. Okay.
(audience applauds)
- So it's great.
- Well, before the show,
Lawrence snagged two
audience members and dressed them
in pieces from his collection.
And I'm not kidding. I
literally told these two ladies,
I was like, y'all look fabulous today.
So tell us what you're wearing.
- So let me introduce
everybody to Rose and Isabelle.
And maybe you guys stand up.
So let's start with Rose.
- [Kelly] Y'all look great.
- And Rose is wearing my
open-front Bianca Cardigan,
over the Black Milena Tank.
And then I finished off the
look with the Debbie Jogger.
And I've got to tell you,
there's something about leopard print
that I just think is so chic, so powerful,
so sexy, and that Bianca
open-front cardigan,
you can be wearing so many ways.
You can belt it. You can find a brooch,
pull it all the way to the side
and create the perfect wrap dress.
Every woman needs a tank top
that is figure flattering.
It's a tunic length
with a t-shirt hemline.
And ladies who doesn't
want a jogger pants.
- Oh my God. Great job.
- [Lawrence] And the
Bianca, machine washable.
(audience applaud)
- Oh, you got me there.
- And the jogger, hidden pockets.
- That's awesome. Oh
my God. I love pockets.
So wait, so what's next?
- Okay. The next up is Isabelle,
and I wanted to elevate her wardrobe.
And I think nothing
elevates a wardrobe better
than a little shimmer and shine.
Which is why I put her in
this beautiful bronze piece.
I put her in the Tracey top.
It's a tie front top that you
can tie in a beautiful bow.
- Love it.
Or undo when you go out and
have cocktails with the girls.
And the same matching
metallic bronze pants
called the Christine.
And as you can see,
each piece is extremely figure flattering.
I celebrate women of all shapes and sizes.
Extra small to 3X.
- Yeah.
And the thing that I love
about these pieces the most,
it's how you feel.
And that's why my CAxLZ partnership
with Connected Apparel
is all about classics
for women to feel beautiful.
- All right. Well, I'm
so proud of you Lawrence.
I'm liking your posts right now.
Go to kellyclarksonshow.com
to learn more about CAxLZ.
(crowd applauding)
That's not all though.
So, to thank you two
for being overachieving
audience members today
and looking quite fabulous.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pin Makers of G2,
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
is giving you each $500
for just being rad.
- Thank you.
- So you both get that.
- [Lawrence] And I'm
giving them their outfits.
- [Kelly] Yes, you're
getting more than that then.
- [Lawrence] That's so good.
- [Kelly] Well, thank you
ladies, you look beautiful.